F3: we've been covering and sort of charting
the path of right wing media since the November
election, which included mostly in the immediate
all of the right wing network networks coming
to the defense of Donald Trump, insisting
or at least having guests on to freely insist
that actually Donald Trump did win, not Joe
Biden.
And then we saw kind of a fork take place.
Some media outlets like OMON and Newsmax went
very hard for weeks and months interviewing
every single conspiracy theorist with a conspiracy
theory about the election.
This included Mike Lyndell from my pillow,
Sidney Powell, the whole roster, the whole
the whole central casting crew.
Fox News did some of that early.
And Lou Dobbs and Maria Bartiromo stuck with
it longer.
But Fox News did step away a little more quickly,
still engaging with the same ideas, but doing
it in sort of a more coy way to avoid as much
legal legal trouble as possible.
Then we've seen Fox News shift to Biden criticisms
that are pretty much flaccid, like Biden hasn't
done a press conference yet and a lot of Dr.
Seuss coverage there actually on week three
of Dr. Seuss coverage on Fox News right now.
But the last 24 hours on Fox News have been
absolutely out of this world.
M1: Many of us don't regularly consume this
drivel.
So I'm going to give you kind of a tour through
the last 24 hours so you can see how they're
framing the current administration, which
it's quite a popular administration by by
historical standards.
Joe Biden with the highest initial approval
rating of any president in nearly 30 years.
High approval on covid handling the covid
relief bill is popular even with Republican
voters, even though not a single Republican
House or Senate member voted for it.
So I already showed you the Tucker Carlson
kind of playing coy with some antibiotics
or talking points, just a reminder of that
clip.
F5: So all of this should prompt some pretty
tough questions for our public health experts
in this country.
And one of those questions is how effective
is this coronavirus vaccine?
How necessary is it to take the vaccine?
Don't dismiss those questions from anti vaccines,
don't kick people off social media for asking
them, answer the questions.
F3: And then here's other stuff from the last
24 hours.
Maria Bartiromo, who now has a new primetime
show on Fox News, she's been brought over
from Fox Business to Fox News.
She had Donald Trump Jr. on her show last
night, and he casually mentions Joe Biden's
history of sniffing children in the context
of the Andrew Cuomo scandal.
If you're watching, you'll see Maria Bartiromo
is a notable official reaction to this.
M9: Joe Biden probably not the best person
to talk about these things, given his history
of sniffing children, et cetera.
F3: So, Don Junior, really angry and still
desperate for his dad to like him and hear
Don Jr. talks about a predator.
Now, it sounds like Don Jr. is talking about
his own dad, but he's not.
He's talking about Andrew Cuomo.
M9: This guy was made a hero when he seems
like he's maybe the biggest predator in American
politics today.
F3: Now, again, you can stop e-mailing me
saying I'm ignoring the Andrew Cuomo story
or I haven't criticized Andrew Cuomo.
We've covered it extensively.
We've covered the allegations.
And as I said before, Cuomo might have to
resign.
What Cuomo is accused of is terrible.
I've not defended Cuomo once, but if Cuomo
is a big predator for a few accusations against
him, Donald Trump has more than 40 assault
allegations against him, varying from, you
know, an unwanted kiss all the way up to rape.
And Don Jr., as usual, is a total hypocrite.
But imagine being Fox News saying Andrew Cuomo
is accused of sexual harassment and assault.
Let's bring on the son of the guy accused
by more than 40 women to say Andrew Cuomo
is the biggest predator out there.
It's you know, the facts don't matter, of
course.
Then yesterday, Fox News covered a propaganda
event at the U.S. Mexico border with Republicans
at which Republican House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy claimed without evidence that
people from Yemen and Turkey are and Iran
are coming over to the United States by crossing
the US Mexico border illegally.
M10: And we go to monument three and you talk
to those agents.
It's not just people from Mexico or Honduras
or El Salvador.
They're now funding people from Yemen, Iran,
Turkey.
People on are on the terrorist watch list.
They are catching and they're rushing it all
at once.
F3: Yemen, Iran and Turkey, they're coming
over the border.
Multiple lawmakers saying after Kevin McCarthy
claimed us.
We haven't heard that at all.
And multiple lawmakers saying we've never
been briefed about this.
If this is going on, we should be briefed.
But we have no reason to think that this is
going on.
And they're actually seizing on this this
morning.
I wasn't able to pull the clip for today's
show this morning.
Fox now covering it as a story that people
from Yemen and these other countries are coming
over will probably talk about that more tomorrow.
And then Donald Trump's former economic adviser
said that to get rich people to pay more taxes,
you should lower their tax rate.
Take a listen to this fair share.
M11: The way you get upper income people to
pay more in taxes is lower their tax rate.
Not only will I have investment incentives,
they will also have no tax avoidance.
F3: Now, we've already discussed why this
is wrong, and I'm going to try to explain
it again.
They say often that lower taxes on the rich
make the rich want to invest in their business.
That is completely backwards if the tax rate.
Let me I'll set up a scenario for you.
A 20 percent tax rate and a 70 percent tax
rate if the tax rate is 20 percent.
I am more likely to just take my money and
run than if the tax rate is 70 percent.
Why?
Because I'm happier paying a 20 percent tax
rate on my profit than I am paying a 70 percent
tax rate on my profit.
Now, think about it the other way.
Investing in your own business is tax deductible,
right?
If I say I'm going to get all new equipment
for The David Pakman Show, I'm going to spend
20 grand on new equipment.
I don't pay taxes on that 20 grand.
That 20 grand is tax deductible.
So am I more incentivized to avoid a 70 percent
tax rate or a 20 percent tax rate?
The answer is obvious.
You will go through more effort to avoid paying
70 cents on the dollar in tax as you would
to avoid paying 20 cents on the dollar in
tax.
We've talked about this many times before.
So the big takeaway here is understanding
the alternate universe that what we call primary
Fox News viewers.
Are living in people who primarily get their
news from Fox News, even if its opinion and
not news, and I think it's important to understand
that I talked to a couple of years ago, I
went to rural northern Indiana, where where
my girlfriend has some family and spending
time there and seeing people grow up around
their church and shooting ranges.
And they're told every day in church that
abortion is the most important issue.
It's like, of course, they're voting for Republicans.
And I think that similarly understanding the
environment of someone who mostly gets their
news from Fox News and maybe the things that
they're similarly right wing friends and family
share on Facebook, of course, they end up
believing the things that they believe.
And I think it's important for all of us to
understand.